honest yeah but that's like also a good
thing for and by the way this isn't like
a toxic friend or something this is a
good person yeah and so you know when
you stick up for people who
you know who have been there for you it
feels right it makes sense not because
you're expecting anything back from
these people it's just more like
your moral compass guides you this way
and it feels right so you're going to do
what you think what you truly believe is
right yeah and that makes sense yeah
like even like it's hot it's just how it
is like in
5
four
three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
have ed park vp here once again what's
up um last time that we were hanging out
we were talking about this and i don't
know if this is like a super la thing
but i think we're
we talk about our weight a lot yeah
i don't know what that is but we just
did a podcast not too long ago and um
it's weird because once you lose weight
you you do start to realize when you
when you gain it because of we buy
skinny clothes
we're talking about this [ __ ] we're like
oh i lost this weight
i could wear some skinny clothes yeah
and then you buy all the stuff that fits
super nice and you know you're a lot
more athletic you feel good and then uh
recently for me i started working out
again because we were hanging out last
time we were eating at denny's like a
bunch of fat asses
you know
it's a funny story there's another funny
story about it
we were at denny's and then we're like
oh yeah i've been gaining weight
but you know i see him ever
intermittently and i don't really notice
these things yeah and then i remember
just after we had that conversation like
yeah i think i gained some weight too
and so
about a couple of weeks ago i decided to
work out again and i had this shirt this
you know this sweat wicking shirt that i
usually wear for when i work out let me
tell you something man if you've ever
seen a human turn into a [ __ ] seal
i
put this shirt on right and it's i i
don't know if this is true i might have
been i might be making this up but i
could hear like a squeegee
the air pockets under your like armpits
yeah
and then it was just molding over my man
breasts so well and i could see every
crevice in my body i'm like bro
did i gain this much weight yeah
like the flesh is coming out of the
sleeves and you know people will leave
comments and they're like dude you gain
weight and i'm like
[ __ ] you don't know [ __ ] they were
right
you don't know how wide-angle lenses
look like yeah i was like camera adds 26
pounds bro what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you don't know [ __ ]
they do know [ __ ] yeah they do it you
can see it yeah that shirt man that was
it's not embarrassing but it was just so
uncomfortable yeah and i was so stubborn
guess what i wore that [ __ ] to the gym
hey if you can rock it with all the
confidence that you need then who cares
what other people are like dude he's
really bugged
i gained some weight too i gained 30
pounds since last summer bro how much
were you weighing then
well um i had a i had a
i had a snag because of a mental health
issue okay um i don't know if i want to
talk about it yet but i'm like waiting
like building up to talk about this
event
but um at that point i was i was going
doing well with keto fasting and working
out i think i could do like 15 pull-ups
at that point
um then um i had a really bad mental
health crisis and i like couldn't eat
when i put food in my mouth i felt like
throwing up oh [ __ ] yeah because um the
stress and the depression i was going
through at that time didn't allow me to
like to swallow food
so i actually got down at like 136
like and i was frail yeah yeah i felt
frail too um like i didn't move around a
lot and stuff too
and in order for me like i knew look at
myself in the mirror this was an
unhealthy skinny i was like i have to
eat i have to eat and so i had to stop
doing keto
you know so i started
trying to put more food in my mouth and
it was very little at a time and before
you know it
i couldn't stop myself
i can't eat hey dude let me tell you
something dude carbs is a gateway drug
bro yeah
oh my god dude it's like a vampire that
just been drinking pig's blood this for
thousands of years i just started with
rice
and next thing i'm eating [ __ ]
cheesecakes on the weekend you're so
funny dude this i don't give a [ __ ] if
you guys don't give a [ __ ] about these
conversations this fat people talk
so with just you know i i've been
watching what i eat i still eat what i
want just portion controlling it right
yeah
but
one night edrick and z come over and
they wanted to celebrate my my birthday
yeah and they're like hey let's
let's just what do you want to eat and i
was like oh there's like you know some
chinese food spot so i kind of like
racked up a list of stuff
and then it's like i don't really want
to eat chinese but what about pizza
i just looked at them i'm like don't say
that
don't say those forbidden words here
like i can't say no dude i ate this
pizza
and when i remember when i bit into it
and the reason why i it's not like i
can't eat pizza but pizza generally is
one of the worst foods you could have
for yourself
extremely high fat and extremely high
carbs it's just you it's one or the
other yeah you know what i mean but
pizza is just one of those just
demonically delicious things that you
can have yeah and i don't even know if
this pizza was good but i ate that [ __ ]
i ate that [ __ ] i was like hey who the
[ __ ] the chef yeah
yes what the [ __ ] who's the chef i was
so
happy eating that pizza right but guess
what because i was eating you know foods
that are generally like whole foods that
are healthier for you i got [ __ ] sick
because i've been eating
i don't want to say clean i want to say
i've been eating correctly yeah um for
the past couple weeks and i ate that
pizza and the next day i had [ __ ]
choro baby i had [ __ ] diarrheas
that's the that's the weird thing about
that kind of [ __ ] like this carb oval or
overload hangover yes right like where
you just like like i can have too much
like coca-cola and feel sick too yeah
yeah or like you know you eat oh my god
just the other week i had this i found
this bag of candy in my cupboard it's
from halloween
and i [ __ ] tore that [ __ ] up
dude i'm telling you man i don't know
what it is but marielle you know during
the time when she has her period she
always craves dark chocolate yeah and
she's like dude i'm saving this for my
period her period came there was no
chocolate
i ate it
oh [ __ ] i ate all of it oh i love all of
the chocolate and this is i was going
into dude every day i was making pasta
in the morning i will i woke up and i
made pasta carbonara that's eggs that's
uh guanchale fat
and just a [ __ ] ton of pecorino romano
yeah and you this creamy egg cheesy
sauce i ate that [ __ ] [ __ ] like six
days in a row because i was obsessed
with it i couldn't stop eating it right
black pepper just delicious and the next
thing you know
my [ __ ] shirt fits like a wetsuit
yeah
like what is this nonsense why is it so
hard to [ __ ] lose weight but gaining
it's like that right like literally like
this it was steven's birthday last
weekend and i tried on some button nuts
and those buttons were just about to pop
couldn't wear them i have these pants
that i that usually fit big on me and
i'm like oh these are my emergency pants
they're my pants now
there's no one it's not for an emergency
this is the only one that fits me
yeah dude we're just back to stretchy
pants now yeah and i measured my waist
the other day and my waist during the
time and i know this sounds like me
being obsessive about you know having a
small waist and being chiseled and fit
it's not that it's i realized i was
gaining weight because how i felt right
yeah you know like i felt a little gross
but my skin was getting bad and i'm like
this is like the side of me you know
having an unhealthy lifestyle i measured
my waist i was at 35 i'm like dude i'm
supposed to be at 33 32. i was like oh
[ __ ] i gained three inches in my waist
lo and behold i weighed myself i was
226.6
and i was like oh [ __ ] i gained about 20
pounds yeah and then um which i already
knew but i think
to me it wasn't anything because i was
just wearing like oversized shirts and
when you wear oversized shirts it's
perfectly fine yeah when your oversized
shirt starts to fit like a [ __ ]
athletic tee that's when you know
there's an issue
and then i just started like okay i
gotta i gotta you know check what i eat
and it got to a point for a moment dude
i thought i was gonna be vegetarian for
a little bit
you know what's weird so check the [ __ ]
out i was i've been grilling a lot but i
started eating meat you know just i
don't say copious amounts but just you
know beef and whatever steaks and
i started eating beef and started making
me nauseous really for a second though i
was scared i was gonna be vegetarian
man i started freaking out okay so so
like i
you know me like
i ate pork belly for like three years
straight yeah doing keto and [ __ ] just a
high fat easier easiest thing to eat
yeah so last year
like when i went through that and i
tried to eat pork belly again
not nausea
i just wanted to throw up what is that
because that was the weird thing when i
was i was i had to up my protein yeah
right i was getting nauseous eating the
meat so i'm like oh am i going to be
vegetarian oh [ __ ] bro i'm legit yeah i
tear up a little bit you had to like
look into what vegans
yeah do i have to not eat meat yeah you
know but then it went away and i was
fine i'm back to juice i i just had pork
belly for the first time since last
summer today before i got here for real
yeah like where that thick fat ass
costco kind because that's the only kind
i like i buy yeah i i finally cooked it
and i ate it and i was like oh [ __ ] i
can eat it again i can get back into
keto sometimes like when i look at when
i talk about my weight and
it's not about weight it's just being
healthier
sometimes i it reminds me of that
in white chicks when she was trying to
get dressed and she's like
look at this back fifth day and i feel
like i'm doing that to myself sometimes
but
i do that i do that i do it all the time
i grab my tits when i'm fasting and i'm
like listen you fat [ __ ] there's
so much energy here yeah like you can
literally like and i'll grab my stomach
man so like um you know i used to have a
huge belly when i was up to 240.
i actually lost 12 inches
cheese because when i was that big i had
to get tailored shirts
because i'm only five seven five eight
but i'm so wide
oh my shirts would go down my knees to
get a large extra large so i had to get
these tailored shirts to shorten the
torso but keep it wide
you know and also help like contour it
so it's a little bit more v-ish you know
it's so funny when you're hella fat
you're trying to get contouring stuff
but it's like just lose the weight fast
yeah exactly i spent eight hundred
dollars on these shirts these tailored
shirts jeez yeah a whole set of them
that's what i thought to myself and
after i lost the weight i was like i
can't believe i spent the money to
tailor shirts instead of just losing
[ __ ] weight yeah and you could save
money by not eating yeah
exactly
i couldn't give up one so i put more
money into the other
but yeah like i lost so i went to go get
church tailored again and they measure
my stomach i lost 12 inches off my
stomach
right but then you know like i had like
a very saggy stomach yeah yeah yeah yeah
where my skin had grown and stretched
but what i've this past year i've gained
30 35 pounds
like you don't see it on my face as much
right it goes straight to my stomach
my belly expands first like crazy yeah
yeah marielle always just says his thing
about me she goes you have the nicest
looking legs but your upper body doesn't
match
she just said that to me today sometimes
she just destroys me and she doesn't
even know but it's a compliment yeah
like
we went to go get like some taiwanese uh
like shave ice dessert and she goes you
have really nice legs but that stuff up
there
doesn't look the same
she just goes into the store i'm like
dude what the [ __ ] are you my parents
yeah i know it's like a [ __ ] like
slight motivation yeah yeah but she's
she's always loving but she's just like
just an observation i understand because
my legs are really slender yeah they're
like muscular and it's only because i
walked eight miles a day yeah so the
calves are just [ __ ] veiny and
they're right they're muscular that's
cause i'm walking up hills for eight
miles it's like a polynesian korean
thing yeah we use a big cat calves right
yeah
yeah and so i it's weird when i'm i'm at
this point now where like i um i'm
trying to understand like my
relationship with food and you know why
i have this certain addiction towards
these foods and sometimes it's really
hard to process because after i eat this
pasta i'm just like by the way it's you
know if anybody who's out there who's
like a dietitian if you're thinking that
i'm going forgoing things in you know
the name of you know pseudohealth it's
not that i'm talking about when i eat
pasta there's like you would think there
was an atta italian family of five
waiting
dude yeah like they're like is it these
are for me yeah yeah know you put a
danny spaghetti in front of me i'm gonna
go [ __ ] with this the weirdest thing
about him yeah i mean like the way i eat
like pasta it's like yeah you think it's
for you know [ __ ] you know giuseppe
giuseppe you're gonna have a little
pasta so i i actually read this book uh
it's called sapiens right incredible
book it's like an alien wrote a book
about humanity
it's as if yeah an alien gave a book
report about human history
so it's like looking at us like from 30
000 feet in the air and watching us what
we do
and there's so there's one theory about
like our dependence not dependence but
how we're both you know fat energy and
carb energy
right because as hunter-gatherers and
caveman and all that [ __ ] we just we
kill and eat meat and fat right but then
um
every now and then right
like fruits in nature would be pretty
rare
you'd come across a fruit tree right
they
didn't they stay they predict that they
didn't just eat one yeah because if you
didn't have sugar back then and you had
like one strawberry of of some you know
bush or some [ __ ]
that sugar would ignite in your brain
right like because i felt it too when i
was on deep keto and i didn't eat sugar
for like a year or some [ __ ]
and then my brother-in-law took me to m
grill and they have a [ __ ] grilled
pineapple delicious by the way and when
i ate that [ __ ] i couldn't hold back my
tears i could feel
japanese out of it yeah
i could feel my hair standing up i can
feel ting tingling in my fingers down to
my legs and my toes like i felt the
sugar high i felt it so they assumed
like back then like the theory is that
um
because you're in survival mode
constantly eating meat and fat that once
you have that carb your brain craves
more knowing that for survival you have
to stock up so when you go eat meat
again you'll store that
fat in your body because of all the
carbs you eat so
it's called like the sugar gorge theory
or something where a caveman would see a
tree and just wouldn't just eat one
they'll eat all of it so to this day
we get a pint of ice cream we're not
gonna just do one scoop we might eat the
whole [ __ ] thing and be like where
what happened how many times does that
happen how did i eat all this candy how
did i eat all these you say this now
dude literally i bought this uh ice
cream from costco yeah it was avocado
ice creams and in my mind i rationalize
oh this is healthy
[Laughter]
there was four pints of it right yeah
it's gone in two days
right and you're like what the [ __ ]
happened and this you know it wasn't me
it was muriel
she goes oh you ate all the dark
chocolate okay at least i have ice cream
full circle
i came back to bite you
[Laughter]
do you eat right this whole thing and
then you're like i don't know
that's like that's a human very human
thing because of our nature to need to
survive is to eat that's why i stay away
from sugar because i know i can't just
have one that's the hardest thing that's
why i choose not to buy certain things
in this household i mean she knows how
to portion control so well like if she
has like she could eat like a half a
tortilla and she goes oh i'm good
no no my friend that's crazy
are you crazy i'm going to have you know
tortillas i'm going to have you know
frioles we're going to have you know
erosk or you know or
whatever you talk about i just have one
yeah that's my poor mexican accent
i'm going to eat everything my friend
yeah like i am going to go to [ __ ]
town that's why i don't go to taco spots
anymore it's not one taco so not too
like i don't talk about this a lot
anymore because that was in my past but
remember when i first got here i was
telling you about my drug problems yeah
yeah i swear to god sugar is the next
closest thing to cocaine really yeah so
i i treat sugar like a narcotic
because i know like
sugar is just as addictive
you know if not more than cocaine oh man
i'm telling you dude i i unders i don't
have much of a sweet tooth but i'll tell
you this when i'm not when i reduce the
amount of uh refined sugars yeah right
because a lot of the because i i i'm not
on a keto diet so i eat carbs right but
i'll eat you know stuff with just fiber
yeah so if it's fruits there's a lot of
dietary fiber in it um i'll still have
white rice but i moderate it you know
i'm just not going ham on it yeah but
literally like after a workout and then
i i'll eat
like you know if you when you see like
this a video of somebody lost in the
desert and then they get a basket of
food in front of them and you see them
stuff their face that's what i do to
berries
you know where's the [ __ ] chef you
know
your brain can't stop
your brain can't stop it craves it it
wants it it's that addictive
the so that's what i mean like a sugar
addiction to me is the same as a drug
addiction the symptoms of a sugar
addiction is obesity
yeah you know so like even lebron james
like he's always looked [ __ ] fit his
entire career right yeah and then
he did the
zero sugar diet and he lost 20 more
pounds that's crazy of just like the
body fat that's left all over his body
and he got shredded yeah yeah for you
um i know cause you're comparing it to
wait how did you how did you start doing
cocaine
[Laughter]
let's say
um so you know i used to drink like a
lot right yeah a lot a lot oh was that
the balancer yeah so um years and years
of drinking and one night
um you know it's like the end of this
momo obviously
and it's like towards the end of the
night i'm so drunk as [ __ ] and i'm like
[ __ ] like i don't know if i can drive or
some [ __ ] right and this guy we both
know him
um
he's like hey want to do a bump like
you'll be straight
right i'm like and because i'm so drunk
usually i would think about it i was
like yeah let's do it like my first time
so i do a key bump
and he was [ __ ] right i was sober i
was straight so really yeah
that's like that [ __ ] on that denzel
washington movie the flight yeah flight
yeah you would drink so much she would
just do a bump of cocaine and he was
straight and then you go back to
drinking some more
what is it why does that happen because
of people like you know we we have our
addiction issues and we just go hard
like
for a long time i didn't know how to sit
down and just have a beer
i had to get [ __ ] up
oh yeah
one right yeah i couldn't just have a
buzz and have a conversation i i just
had to get blacked out drunk so it's
it's definitely like an addiction issue
it's a binging issue as well like where
you just
you have you work
long hours and go all day sober and once
you get home or it's finally the weekend
you [ __ ] stuff your brain full of
chemicals yeah yeah i used to chill out
what is because i've never done cocaine
before what does it feel like
um
like a really great adderall like a fun
adderall
like disco is actually good music
so
the last time i did it right my big last
hurrah i went to colombia
and i got some real cool good [ __ ] [ __ ]
some good [ __ ]
and you know that song
so gasoline they make cocaine out of
gasoline and coca leaves that's why so
when it's like pure and it's good you
can smell the gasoline oh really if when
you don't it's like chopped up so much
with like baby formula or creatine or
some white powder right and it gets
chopped up when it gets to america
you know and then it burns your [ __ ]
nose and like you know when you get
water up your nose yeah like you get a
foreign substance in your nose and it
burns that's what it feels like when you
get bad cocaine that's what it feels
like yeah oh [ __ ] so
like i went to colombia
it was fairly easy to get it off the
street we got a whole eight ball it's
crazy because it's only this big as a
rock yeah and then when you start
breaking it up oh my god it was endless
i did it every day for an entire week
holy [ __ ] yeah so what is it is it an
upper it's a cr yeah
crazy upper so like i i love like trap
like hip hop right after when on cocaine
it's a million times better then
i i went on spotify and i looked for a
cocaine mix
and they had a bunch of disco that's
hilarious oh my god i get it i get disco
on it like dude disco is really cool
yeah
and then you start and then so you i go
back through these 80s mixes and these
80s songs built off a cocaine and it's
like
this is some good [ __ ] people like
[ __ ] on that [ __ ] dude yeah no i i
can get
i get cocaine dick one time like i was
out partying and you know met this girl
and
we were just drinking and then we would
go to andorraban after and she she had
cocaine with her it was a date yeah and
it was so [ __ ] it you know like whatever
we did it and
but yeah when we got back to her place
yeah it's it's not hard it's it's like
not easy to get it up oh really yeah
that's nuts man like i've never been
interested in doing like any hard drugs
i don't really like drugs in general as
i drink this alcohol
but um socially acceptable drugs you
know like like alcohol is different
because when you're drunk
sometimes you're so drunk you don't even
know you're drunk
it feels like you're in control yes
that's the biggest difference i think
that's why timmy alcohol has been a
little more tolerable because i even
though you're drunk you still feel like
you're in control that's why cocaine can
be dangerous like i said like you eat
one little fun sized bar of candy from
halloween right that's not enough you'll
eat another yeah and another and then
another then another and
before you know it you ate the whole bag
of candy like cocaine like
some days like you just can't [ __ ]
stop
oh [ __ ] like
i had to start giving myself a timer
like a 30 minute timer between my bumps
oh really especially when it's that
readily accessible to you
like
it's so addictive that you just keep
jumping why'd you stop doing cocaine
um well the come downs are really bad
too if you're that high the lows are
really bad does that [ __ ] up with like i
know they were talking about some of the
side effects with e yeah you know
because it
what is that part of your brain that
that causes euphoria
um
yeah we can't remember whatever i'm not
a scientist all right guys but either
way that part of the brain that releases
that chemical that creates euphoria and
happiness it gets overloaded so much
that when they're off that they're
almost like depressed they're very
depressed yeah yeah yeah it's so like
because um it really so much
yeah dopamine and serotonin yes that it
[ __ ] up like your your regulatory
production the same thing that happens
with people who take steroids yeah they
have to take estrogen to you know all
this other stuff right right right yeah
so the balance is way off so i know
people who have a whole concoction of
vitamins and minerals for when they
drop e so they can recover better but
then this for the same reason i don't
like to come down on e although it's
[ __ ]
great and fun to be on sometimes it
takes like an entire week with the come
down like how shitty i feel oh that
payoff is terrible yeah so that's why
people get addicted to it because they
need to get rid of that feeling but yeah
yeah
because you're so low and like you know
what cocaine does the trick anyway
it's it's a deadly cycle like with a lot
of drugs that's why i'm not a big fan of
like that's why i like cbd products
because
or even when you take delta eight things
like delta eight the high feels
different you know yeah yeah it's not
the same right yeah i've given you you
know gummies and stuff like that
it's a lot more controlled it's a lot
more subtle uh versus you know you saw
me at my worst
you know
you know yeah i was in another universe
yeah you know just like what is time
yeah you got [ __ ] up i was [ __ ] up
bro yeah um but what i found out is like
i found my happy medium
yeah when you can handle your [ __ ] is
when it works yeah i don't like
uh thc edibles yeah um i don't like um
what do you call it so i was hanging out
with dan
at robin's place right and he had a vape
yeah right and i didn't realize those
thc vape stuff
dude it's hella so strong
like what 90 something percent bro
why do people not tell me these things
yeah you took a huge hit i took two oh
my god yeah two fat [ __ ] hits
and i'm sitting there and our buddy dan
he's like telling me about what's going
on with his life and he's opening his
heart to me and you know what all i was
saying in my head was
make sure that you look like you're
paying attention
[Laughter]
i just can't
it to myself in my head
if he finds out that you don't know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about he's going
to be crushed just nod and pretend like
you know what he's saying and i was just
sitting there just yeah bro i feel you i
get it i was high as a [ __ ] i
hated it yeah i [ __ ] hated it so you
can't do the vape pens then those things
are [ __ ] harsh bro they're all
intense yeah that's that's like the
level where marijuana is at right now
it's [ __ ] long
and i just kept thinking every time i
had these experiences i'm like oh my god
is this the shabbos experience all over
again
so i had the slight it wasn't like the
delay i had at the shabbo place right
the shovel place was literally like a 10
second delay yeah i was blasted gone
yeah and it's just where you picture
inside of a picture inside of a picture
you know where literally i'm floating
above
telling you look i've been dead i'm dead
dude you're like
why is
everything so slow
that's what you said yes
but
when you find your happy meal when you
can control your high like look keith
richards the guitarist for the rolling
stone has been on heroin for the past 60
years
that's crazy but it's because he's
controlled he has the same dosage for
the last 60 years oh wow that's how he
functions ozzy osbourne has this weird
genetic i don't know if i want to call
it a disorder but it's the reason why he
can take such hard drugs and never die
he doesn't [ __ ] with him it was a
genetic it's a genetic thing in in him
that yeah he just doesn't he's a
superhero from it yeah and he's taken
everything off you know but obviously
i'm not like we're not i'm not here
telling you guys oh you guys try cocaine
like no it's bad yeah bad i've seen
people's lives ruined with it too
you know i was trying to make the
analogy between sugar yeah being bad i
like smoking joints though yo you do
the classic just [ __ ]
little [ __ ] joint yeah because the
way that it makes you high is way more
subtle and it lasts a lot shorter yeah
so
uh smoking with robin and i just you
know i was like damn i haven't done this
in a hot second i took a couple puffs
i'm like this is normal yeah this is how
it should make you feel it's almost
undetectable yeah right and it reminded
me of this
when you just sit and chill you have a
glass of wine or a little bit of like
liquor
you can sit and chill right yeah that's
when you can find that happy medium is
like the right place that's why i smoke
marijuana yeah food now because all that
other [ __ ] i was going hard obviously
man i was in a crazy mental state but
where
marijuana takes me is like where i'm not
destroying myself yeah yeah internally
you know i'm not doing the [ __ ] because
my life is so
this who's the first person that gave
you cocaine
oh wait you mentioned like we know this
person then yeah yeah oh okay i was a
friend in seattle but then you know over
time like especially like in in in cape
town
it shows up everywhere like cocaine has
become so accessible now yeah like it's
kind of weird yeah um
you know people used to have certain
amount of judgments toward people who
smoked weed right and now we have these
weird situations where like literally in
cape town i meant like come yeah people
are just doing bumps in the bathroom
yeah dude this wasn't like this like six
years ago no like why the [ __ ] is
everybody doing cocaine now dude it's
like yeah it is
it's made a huge comeback yeah it's just
the party scene i guess has changed
where it's just like the stigma behind
cocaine isn't there anymore i mean the
weeknd all of his songs are about
cocaine you know the freaking funniest
story ever one of our friends that we
know the first time he ever did cocaine
he did it on accident so accident he was
he was at a [ __ ] uh lounge
and he was dancing i know this girl was
cute and then she was like dancing with
him like super close grinding with him
or whatever and she was super close to
him like about to kiss him and she kind
of whispered in his ear she goes he goes
you want to do a bump he's innocent boy
she doesn't know what to do he doesn't
know what a bump is so
he goes sure and then um she goes just
breathe in
he breathes in and then he's just like
dancing or whatever and everything
becomes hella intense and he goes yeah i
did drugs
he's such a clean guy yeah and he said
he runs into the bathroom and he just
starts
holds his knees together
he starts freaking out he's like i did
drugs
by some cute girl
yeah i'm always on the moon like the
thing about cocaine is why it's
dangerous it's because it is fun yeah
yeah it is fun but you you do pay a
price i think it's that it's the scary
part for me is when you said that the
the come down is so harsh
that having to like yeah if you know
what can fix it why not do it it's like
having a headache and not taking tylenol
yeah like why wouldn't you yeah which is
really really really scary the other
thing is just deal with it deal with it
and then maybe and then all of a sudden
in front of me again another weekend you
know yeah
my sister actually told me a story um
because she works at a hospital like
she was coming out
to have lunch and leaving there was a
group of people doing cpr on a person in
in front of outside the like the
driveway of the hospital
you know and when she found out what
happened was like one of the employees
was eating lunch
having a sandwich on the bench in front
of the hospital and then started choking
on it
he couldn't breathe and then like i
guess later they found out
um he had a heart attack while having
lunch it was because he had massive
amounts of cocaine in his system
holy [ __ ]
dude i know this is such a sidetrack but
um so two things happened actually in
the past few days that i only just found
out about um so sacramento had its
biggest mass shooting recently my
hometown yeah yeah did you see that [ __ ]
right i didn't see it
it was i think it was like nine people
that died it was after some kind of like
tyler the creator concert but yeah
unloaded a hundred rounds bro
[ __ ] nuts and then i find out um
through a friend of mine um there's
somebody that i met once but she was
really really close to this guy and i
met him too guy is the he is the [ __ ]
like he's on his [ __ ] he's like uh he's
like in production yeah um
just dope like we worked on a project
together and i met him and like this
guy's [ __ ] dope i would love to like
work with him again one day
um
my friend was moving and then he was
helping her move and whatever
and um i might be paraphrasing this
story a little wrong just because it was
so shocking to hear this
uh she
uh she basically calls him because he
was supposed to either help her the next
day to finish up he doesn't pick up his
phone at all
right doesn't pick up his own doesn't
know what's going on and then the next
thing you know
she finds out through somebody else that
the reason why he wasn't picking up his
phone is because he died
shooting he got shot up in the middle of
night out in like the burbank or
hollywood area it's actually a news
article so you guys can read it up um so
that's why i'm okay talking about it
because it's out in public
he got shot like three times in his car
and he crashed into a car and then they
just bounced and they killed him while
he was driving [ __ ] was it like a
drive-by just gang initiation type don't
[ __ ] know this is 330. this guy's a
full-grown adult the sweetest nicest
dude ever i'm talking about there's
absolutely no way this was like drug or
gang involved at all like that's he's
like one of those guys yeah shot three
times died
in his car and it crashed
how [ __ ] nuts what the [ __ ] i don't
know who did it
literally don't know who did it
man i mean like that that sounds similar
towards like
a few years ago this
this [ __ ]
girl in hollywood i think it was in
front of the roosevelt hotel
somebody ran up behind her and blew her
head off with a shotgun point blank shot
you know when you go point blank with a
shotgun it it's disgusting
yeah
he blew her [ __ ] head off yeah ran
away so the cops were believing that it
was like a gang initiation thing that he
had he had to do it go murder someone to
get into this game why like that though
guy yeah
like that's so fun she was walking with
her boyfriend so as a couple walking
down the street they walk they turn off
either i think it's either hollywood or
sunset but where the roosevelt is down
that alley and they just [ __ ]
murdered there's some weird things that
happen um especially when it comes to
like so in
stockton modesto area uh when i was
younger there was a gang that the the
initiation was that they had to uh cut
somebody's achilles tendon
what yeah that's how you got in the gang
a stranger
yeah a stranger so uh
i heard about this [ __ ] right and i'm
like the [ __ ] that's nuts i don't know
if it's true and then lo and behold
there was um
uh it was on the news where they were
warning people about when they pumped
for gas at gas stations late at night
because these guys would um wait under
the car and wait for you to go pump your
gas and then cut your achilles tendon
and that's how they you get into the
gang
what the [ __ ] man crazy dude this
world's [ __ ] this is why i go home
but i'm like cinderella before this uh
clock strikes 12 yeah i'm home yeah and
if i want to drink i'll drink at home
for the rest of the night i don't trust
people anymore people are [ __ ] crazy
dude yeah now i get it when my parents
are like hey make sure that you come
home early because they're worried about
[ __ ] like this because of the [ __ ] that
we've seen in this world yeah it's so
[ __ ] crazy like just this guy just
driving at night
and then getting
shot to death
and nobody knows why yeah nobody [ __ ]
knows why i'm it might have been like
late at night and you know those guys
probably you know most hit him or some
[ __ ] he was like [ __ ] you and then they
shot him up
it could have been something as simple
as it could have been like road rage or
some [ __ ] too it could have been because
i'll tell you this too when i was in i
used to have road rage like crazy and
the reason why i stopped having railways
was number one i realized i'm a terrible
driver yeah so 90 of the time was my
fault
and then the other the other [ __ ] was
like uh i was on the road and um these
cars almost like sideswipe me
i get [ __ ] pissed off and i look over
and i go [ __ ] you like that right this
car slows down and there's a bunch of
tatted up [ __ ] mexican dudes
right hanging out the car window and
they're like what's up and i just looked
at him i would say i said i'm sorry yeah
just say it yeah you're so
sorry [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i was just like you're right
this is what i am it's my favorite is
when you come in with the oh
yesterday korea today america
that's how you get out of it they scared
the living [ __ ] out of me dude and i'm
like oh these guys would have [ __ ]
killed me dude straight up i should have
known by the the card that they had but
they were just
you know i was just feeling a little
brave a little coup de vil like what are
you thinking about it yeah oh really
yeah and i was like one of those
old-fashioned like coupe de vil you know
those long
u-boat cars yeah and they were just
hanging out the [ __ ] what's up [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's just going off on me
and i just sat there just gripping the
steering wheel just oh [ __ ] when you see
a coupe de vil that's too nice and kept
you know well that's when you don't [ __ ]
with it yeah this is a [ __ ] problem
full [ __ ] [ __ ] they said all this
[ __ ] to me i just let it happen yeah but
going back i mean like with all this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] too like
we were talking earlier about my mental
health issues last summer i actually had
to put down the weed
i i'd stopped smoking for like three
months oh [ __ ] how was that
it's not easy yeah it's not easy
especially because i had nightmares
every night what i had nightmares like
every single night so when you're a kid
and you get nightmares right like that's
what i realized like you dream about
monsters and scary [ __ ] that the fears
that you have right
as an adult like my dreams my nightmares
are like worst case scenario situations
like i'll have dreams where my sister
gets caught up in an avalanche and i'm
desperately trying to save her and find
her
really i have dreams where um you know i
i see somebody i hate like um
with somebody that i love
you know that kind of [ __ ] and then i
start struggling with this anxiety in my
dreams so when i wake up i'm [ __ ]
freaked out
you know oh [ __ ] that's a little too
real yeah i like that crazy vivid dreams
that's the one of the biggest symptoms
of marijuana withdrawal
crazy vivid dreams but for me they
weren't like oh [ __ ] i'm flying or
whatever like
the
the dreams are so vivid that even though
like i have a dream every single night
it's so real to me
up to the point where my anxiety is so
out of control in my sleep
when i say this is a dream i instantly
wake up oh [ __ ] yeah and and i'm
sweating and like my heart's pumping and
all that [ __ ] dreams are so trippy too
because i and i i i'm not going to tell
the story again on this podcast i've
said it twice but you know the person
that we talked about before
you know that's a little weird you know
i had a dream about her and it was so
forthcoming in who she is as a person
that it it was almost like a weird
warning like somebody from another realm
was warning me yeah about this girl yeah
because um long story short with it and
yeah i might have told you this too but
essentially went into this like
dark forest and there was a mansion in
it and it was all lit up very pretty and
you go into this like mansion and i go
into a room and it's like a kid's room
and there's a gigantic robot standing
there right yeah and he turns around and
he has the voice of her manager at the
time
and he looks at me and he starts
malfunctioning and he just freaks out
and falls over and you know he's like
freaking out and he goes don't trust
this person yeah what what the [ __ ] are
you talking about and i
look at her and then she turns into a
fox
and then we're running away because i'm
freaking out right because this gigantic
robot is like giving me this like
warning and then we're
we're driving away and this person's a
fox the whole time just sly yeah i saw a
little fox and i eventually you know
long story short i eventually get out
and then but that was like a very
forthcoming dream about who this person
is and i still feel that way about that
and i've always felt that way but that
dream was so vivid to me yeah it's like
oh it's like a representation of who
this person is
and
i
i saw what you saw i mean i didn't have
the same dream as you i mean like the
feelings you had like in your life about
it because like for for us in this
person it was early on for me yeah like
it was literally i met this person for
like a few days and i'm like
i don't like this right yeah i'll be
honest my my first
my first interactions with her was
because i was starstruck yeah you know
like oh my gosh this person is my friend
but um
yeah over time
um
you know you we
we read people really well you know we
we do filmmaking part of our whole thing
is storytelling and you can see a story
being told when people are
are
un unconsciously telling it you yes yes
yes because they're
manipulating
an
idea that they have about their world
yeah so they just live that out almost
to a delusional degree
where it's only true to them but it's
still just the only truth in the world
yeah yeah
so i
yeah like uh
we have a friend and
uh he got divorced
right
and his wife
has been trying to hang out with me yeah
you know not in uh any kind of like
intimate way or whatever but in a sense
that she still wants to be my friend
but for me where i was caught up in this
was
like i was so confused like she's being
really nice yeah you know and she wants
to work with me too
um
and i don't hate her because of the
divorce or anything but for me i was
like
uh is this normal
like because
you you married my best friend
but then i wasn't your best friend
right yeah i mean those are those i'm
pretty sure anybody who's listening to
this too i wonder it'd be dope to hear
in the comments like if you guys have
been through something like this like
what is the proper etiquette because for
me
i don't have emotion it's okay so like
you've you've obviously had many friends
where you're they're dating each other
and you're friends with both of them
yeah it because for me it all depends on
how the relationship developed but i say
that now but i'm a very loyal person and
i'm always going to go with the person
that i was introduced to that person
with right so it's like
you are an introduction because this
person is my really close friend yeah
where am i where does my dedication lie
right and it's not to say that
i don't cherish the moments that i had
with the other person but it's different
it's different now it's like it was
there was conditional the condition was
that this person was the gateway between
our friendship
it's not that we didn't have good
moments but whenever we hung out it was
it wasn't like we were one-on-one it was
us as a group mainly yeah so i don't
really feel and plus like friends do
come and go and i have my stable core
group of friends so if this person goes
i'm not gonna feel a certain way about
it yeah you know yeah so
i don't have any real personal beef but
then i was locked up in my loyalty to my
boy yeah you know this man took care of
me when i was coming out of washington
i'm his bus
like i'm his best friend and i'm
practically his tamagotchi yeah yeah
this guy his whole sole job for me is
like to keep me alive yeah because he's
been there at my worst you know
and
you know they're they're split up and
she's posting
about her new boyfriend you know um
it's pretty quick
to me it's pretty soon or whatever but i
don't i still don't feel any personal
way about that because they're divorced
they can do what she can do whatever the
[ __ ] she wants right
but she's also
like
you know reposting my stories because
she thinks it's funny she's tagging me
in them
and i felt like she was giving this
image that we she and i were still
friends like she's
kind of giving this hey look at this new
generation like look how great this
divorce turned out i'm still friends
with my ex's best friend anything but i
didn't sign up for this story you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah i wasn't trying to
make it go this way i was just being
cool like you guys are broken up but
then
i'm like being painted into this picture
of hers like that this divorce is so
great or whatever or it's just like this
truly amicable modern great divorce
which in a sense it is but i don't have
to be a part of it yeah yeah yeah so
that's what i was thinking so a friend
uh was visiting la and she's divorced
too
she was in a 10-year long relationship
so i asked her like i'm going through
this thing
like
did you try to be friends with your
ex-husband's friends she's like what the
[ __ ] no yeah what the hell we got along
but we we were friends through
associations yeah and she's like
straight up i left the town and all the
people associated with it you know i
don't need to be their friends like kind
of thing so i'm like why
thing in my head why is this person want
to be friends with me that badly after
this you know at least give me some time
yeah yeah yeah you know i i it's it's
weird and i think it's you know
for you or anybody else you're going to
have to think smart it's like what's the
what's what's the idea of this is this
because
do you want to feel good about the
divorce yeah so it really feels like
amicable to you yeah do you need me to
affirm that for you yeah like is that
like am i your token thing for your
guilt or your emotions
right because you know we
it's not amicable
to be straight up with it yeah it's not
amicable
at all yeah so the idea that you know
for this person if they think that it is
that's their reality i'm not i can't say
otherwise that's how what they believe
yeah and we're not trying to get a
debate with him to try to convince him
it's not yeah that's not if that's how
she feels that's how she feels go live
your life but objectively
it's not
amicable you know but you know but i do
see a lot of people kind of create their
own narrative because they want to feel
guilt-free they want to feel good and
you know the first thing is is like you
know having conversations is just oh
it's very amicable nobody asked you yeah
why'd you say that this podcast is
brought to you by raycon my friend shout
outs to ray khan for accompanying me in
my everyday life helping me get my
fitness on because raycon stays in my
ears and provide me entertainment if you
guys don't know what raycon is ray khan
has these everyday earbuds that look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not
budge my friends trust me eight hours of
play time 32 hours of battery life at
half the price of other premium brands i
love them kickboxing running jogging you
best believe i got smell raycons go to
buy recon dot com slash brain today to
get 15 off your recon order that's by
raycon.com brain to score
15 off by raycon.com
brain
the reality being too like why does it
have to be 100 perfect
yeah it doesn't have to be divorces are
messy yeah it is what it is that's the
reality of the situation that's fine
yeah but the idea that you know when you
tell me that she says you know it's
amicable it's like
for who
yeah for you because you found someone
new immediately yeah you know and like
this is not judgment because i don't
know their personal relationship like
that but i do know him
it's not amicable yeah so for her to say
that's a little odd like it's weird you
know what i'm saying and like i said
that's where you could feel a little
emotionally kind of caught in the middle
because somebody in her you know she
might be honest in her own world in her
sense of whatever world that she's
living in she's like oh it's you know
it's the perfect divorce it's great so
for her when she does that it's like
okay i know that it's not
right but at the same time why do you
need me to be around yeah and once again
and i think anybody would feel this way
you might feel like you might be getting
used
and this person too if they are that
delusional they might not even know what
they're doing they're just kind of
carrying on about their ways which is
very odd and i think it's smart for you
too because i'm i'm all about loyalty
for the longest time yeah you know and
for me it's not so much just
you know in terms of friendship loyalty
isn't just because somebody has been
around for a long time is how important
this person to me has has been to be in
my life yeah right um you know for for
you and our friend
your guy's relationship is very very
[ __ ] tight like how much he's been
with you throughout every stage in your
life that's a very special [ __ ] bond
yeah you know and the idea and maybe for
her what she has to think about too it's
like it's not just oh we were both
friends no no no no this is a different
bond yeah no matter how fun we had how
much fun we had or whatever you do not
supersede our personal relationship
and it's not because he's asking it of
you it's what you're comfortable with so
i think it's because maybe she doesn't
have that kind of bond with another
friend and so
with that i can see that she would like
to have that kind of relationship with
me too
but i didn't have that [ __ ] 22 years
with her growing up you know um yeah to
be on that level that takes time but you
know like certain people too they always
[ __ ] on the first date with friendships
like they they think that because you
had a great interaction with somebody a
few times oh yeah you had a great night
going out somewhere just crazy this is
my friend yeah no no
we just hung out yeah we went wild one
night you know where we're drinking and
[ __ ] but like dude i was at a bar i
talked to the bartender we had he's not
my friend
but we had a good time for those 10
minutes doesn't mean we're [ __ ]
friends yeah and those are the people
that are always a little bit scary like
scared about like how they speak about
me to other people they're like this is
my friend no we are not friends
we are not don't say that [ __ ] it
reminds me of this guy like uh i met up
with another friend from seattle to go
have dinner with his other friends i i
don't even know who they are so i'm like
all right you know mutual friends these
guys visiting so we'll get together
and when i get there this guy knows who
i am
and he's dabbing me up and i'm like yeah
i gotta be honest i don't know who you
are and he was mad offended right he's
like don't you remember when we went up
to this guy's house
remember i knew we drank that night like
this person said this person this person
was there dude i was on cocaine yeah
exactly that's what i was saying good
bro i was [ __ ] up at that time yeah in
that time of my life i don't remember a
goddamn thing but this guy was angry
that i didn't remember him the audacity
yeah it's like come on man why do i have
to be your friend either like it's like
cool like we're here you know like i'm
reintroduced to you
i'm so bad with remembering people and
names sometimes because you know when
you're in this city too and you're
you know you're out hanging out you just
meet a bunch of people when you're
always drunk yeah dude there's this one
girl she's very cute
this is our buddy tom's friend
and uh she introduced me herself to me
once
i said hi what are what not apparently i
was like very like nice and kind or
something a little bit flirtatious i
mean again second time what's your name
again what's your name and she goes oh
you met me i was like oh that's right
i'll remember you right third time hey
my name's david
let me tell you something reached out my
hand she just looked at me and walked
away yeah and all up and i in my i never
met her before so i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm just like what a [ __ ] people
understand though like you me a thousand
people a week sometimes yes right this
whole comes up to me goes bro
you [ __ ] forgot her again i'm like
who
who are you talking about i can't forget
something i never met he goes dude you
met her like a bunch of times i was like
she's super cute i was like yeah this
girl's super cute he goes dog you
literally told her last time that you
wouldn't
will not forget her face
and you said my hi my name is david
i [ __ ] up so bad but now i remember
her yeah because he had a very special
interaction right her walking away from
me right it's those core memories yeah
sometimes i just want to see her out on
the street again just so i can
reintroduce myself yeah
just she's a little comfortable she
actually did see me once at an event and
she walked she just [ __ ] snubbed me
she just had it she wanted to give it
back to you yeah she just i i was gonna
say hi right right and she just snubbed
me super hard and i'm like
[ __ ] speaking of being snubbed like
this the the person we were talking
about earlier
because i was just like you know i need
time i'm i'm i'm not there with my boy
like i'm not comfortable you know
hanging out
and
she she gave her play one more time like
why don't we hang out and talk it
through like go have dinner and i
honestly just didn't respond
because i mean i didn't know what to say
yeah yeah
and then she blocked me
she blocked me on all social media hey
sounds like you guys are pretty amicable
yeah that sounds amicable
yeah it's like i'm like it's cool like
everything else i have no personal
issues with you but you divorce is
divorce yeah that's exactly what i said
yeah and this i i don't want people to
think that you're over here like oh i'm
down for my boy it's not because he's
not asking yeah right it's just what
you're comfortable with and that makes
perfect sense too
you know it's like wanting to have your
cake and eat it too it's like oh well
we're split but everything can be just
the same yeah says who what what rule
book is this yeah people create these
like rule books without even knowing
what the [ __ ] game is
you know and that's more offensive to
our buddy that she's divorcing like
he's the only one left in the gutter i
would rather sit in the gutter with my
boy yeah you know what i'm saying like
that's the kind of loyalty like i grew
up with to be honest yeah but that's
like also a good thing for and by the
way this isn't like a toxic friend or
something this is a good person yeah and
so you know when you stick up for people
who you know who have been there for you
it feels right it makes sense not
because you're expecting anything back
from these people it's just more like
your moral compass guides you this way
and it feels right so you're gonna do
what you think what you truly believe is
right yeah and that makes sense yeah
like even like it's hot it's just how it
is like
at the time when jason chen yelled at
you
yeah i mean and i was like what the [ __ ]
you know yeah and it just
it's just because it's the right thing
to do and it makes sense yeah you kind
of protect your friends and you're
mindful of their emotions and you're
gonna be mindful of the person who's the
closest to you over the other person
yeah that's just all that it is there's
no personal feelings and there's a lot
of things that ties us down by our
principles
right and this is one of those things
like
i don't want to break your heart i don't
want to make you feel bad i have i'm not
doing this with the intent to try to
make you upset at me it's just
this is me and this is where i stand
like
like i'm sorry
yeah like it is what it is yeah like
don't take it personally what it is
yeah man this is such a weird situation
i wonder what people if other people
have been through that because i know my
friends who've been through it and they
just like your friend like no we just we
i have my own group of friends and these
are the people and they have theirs and
if we see each other it's cordial we'll
say hi
for this person uh it was different she
did not like her husband right because
her husband
at the time cheated on her with multiple
women yeah so it was
i didn't know right right right right
right because i'm i'm her friend right
i'm not his friend so i guess he was
just out doing his thing
and um
[Music]
she's just she's amicable with his
friends right yeah and i remember i
asked her too i was like hey did you do
you think that her his friends knew she
was probably but that i'm not married to
them yeah so
they're gonna look after he they're
gonna look after their boy they have no
reason to come and tell me even though
we share drinks or whatever it's why
would they step in and break up a family
right you know if i didn't know i
probably would have been happy not
knowing and it would have been great but
the fact is he got caught and i knew
yeah so yeah which is very weird i never
thought somebody would have that kind of
pers like perspective about that yeah so
i was like oh i mean that's a very
[ __ ] mature logical way of looking at
it yeah taking out her emotions probably
because she's cried enough yeah she
doesn't want to cry over him anymore she
doesn't want to like you know she's
moved on i mean this was like a couple
years ago so she's moved on now she's
remarried you know has a new kid not so
it's like you know she talks to other
kids and i'm kidding
she's um she's good to go but divorce is
such a messy thing and i think it's the
idea of people just wanting to have
their cake and eat it too but i would be
kind of mindful and careful like you or
it's like what is the purpose of us
being friends yeah right is it because
you're really going to miss me is it
because if you if i'm not around you're
going to feel devastated probably not
yeah what is it with my affirmation
which only speaks on your insecurity
yeah yeah sorry you know like yeah
you're exposing that yeah that's kind of
weird man i don't know because i i
wouldn't think that doesn't make any
sense to me because i honestly wouldn't
think that she would yeah especially
because the way the the your guys's
friendship develop you guys usually had
problems with each other a little bit
yeah yeah i mean there was like some
friction here and there yeah i think but
the
natural course of a lot of friendships
is taking a break with somebody and then
coming back like everything's cool yeah
and
sometimes i'm not exactly down with that
but then i had an obligation to my
[ __ ] best friend who's married to her
right yeah i'm not gonna stir up trouble
and i was like i'm not gonna hold
grudges
and
my boy loves this girl and i'm gonna
show the same unconditional love that he
does because he's my boy
you know like i wasn't team him and her
i'm team this relationship as long as i
go together but [ __ ] once it's over
you know like and i didn't have a hand
in whether it was good or not i just
wanted to make sure everything was happy
but it's over now i no longer have that
obligation yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's just truly how i feel like i was
doing this for my boy you know what's so
funny so
my my best friend is now broken up with
this girl right matter once i [ __ ]
hate her
um
and he knows how i am yeah right he
knows that i'm a very
i have tact but i'm very straightforward
yeah more packed now than i was when i
was younger for sure and you know this
yeah you know we're talking about when
it comes to brutal honesty
i'm way more tactful now i'm a lot more
careful with my words and um
you're not no korean doctor yeah exactly
you know not sticking my finger up your
butt like a puppet
and so
i i met her
they're broken up now and
she has this habit of trying to
always play devil's advocate when she
doesn't have to
right
what's with those people i don't know
why he's trying to start up [ __ ] exactly
well the other side i'm like do you
really believe it or not yeah exactly
and so like i only played devil's
advocate on a podcast because we're
talking about subjects that we don't
really know about yeah but when somebody
tells you their personal story and
they're opening up to you for you to
side with somebody else that you've
never even met it's very [ __ ] odd
yeah nobody's asking you to take sides
and so when i was um
talking to her i was talking to her
telling her a very personal story about
and then we were talking for hours at
this point
and
telling her a personal story
about
my brother when he went through his
breakup and you know he was going
through it at the time
and um
i was telling her that this girl was
kind of crazy like she was a bit of a
psychopath and i know because i met her
yeah and you know and i'm not going to
get into the details of his breakup but
it was pretty [ __ ] messy yeah and
then she out of nowhere
for some [ __ ] girl power reason
starts defending this girl and this girl
like daniel could ruin my brother's life
yeah you know and i stopped and i looked
at her and i was like hey can i ask you
something i was like in what sense do
you think that it's appropriate for you
to vehemently defend somebody who abused
my brother yeah right when you've never
met my brother and you've never i'm not
asking you to break this down like
you're a detective i listen to your
personal story your trials and
tribulations and i thought i could open
myself up to you and now you're over
here saying that basically insinuating
that my brother's an [ __ ] yeah like
he deserved it yeah i'm like what are
you talking about it's like well you
know because when women did that and she
just she goes as as somebody who's in
counsel i'm a counselor and i looked at
her and i was like i know counselors too
by the way by the way i was a youth
minister yeah you don't ever go ahead
and then
what's it called disregard somebody's
trauma in a conversation that's like a
first no-no that you never ever [ __ ]
do and that's what you're doing i was
like what gives you the right and you
know and she just sat there and i
started lecturing her about number one
like the fact that you're sitting here
disregarding and just being extremely
dismissive of my personal feelings and
in this person very personal
conversation and she gets really quiet
yeah and i have the audience audacity to
give yourself the authority because
you're a counselor exactly and i told
her i was like do people like it when
you go ahead and say hey because i'm a
counselor that you you feel like you
have the right to say whatever the [ __ ]
you want like you could psychoanalyze me
i never asked for that yeah right i was
like we're just having a regular
conversation if this is how you carry
yourself i'm pretty sure that you you
probably have a lot of personal issues
with having friends and i think that got
her because she doesn't have a lot of
friends well lo and behold guess what
i'm no idiot and and i think it hit her
she starts crying
right and she goes like i'm sorry i
didn't even know i was doing that and i
was like well you were and it was super
disrespectful yeah and so i was telling
i was like okay it's like you know i
just feel like because you know your
brother you know i'm a black woman and
he's dating a black woman i was like
she's white
she goes oh i'm like oh so you're racist
now too so she didn't wait so she didn't
even know this girl was so she just
wanted to defend her because she just
assumed that she he was dating a black
woman she goes a black woman i got a
defender it's like i was like
i understand all that stuff but no
yeah like i literally just told you my
brother just went through some
traumatizing [ __ ] and you immediately
defended this woman and just you know
started you know blaming my brother
who's a victim and she doesn't even know
who this person is no doesn't know who
this person is oh my god so i'm like why
do you do that and then she couldn't
even explain herself she was i don't
know and then the funny thing is is like
as she's crying she's apologizing she
goes you know this is probably i didn't
realize i had this behavior
um i i didn't mean to make you feel that
way blah blah blah and then i was like
asking i was like do you do this to a
lot of people because i'm pretty sure
this isn't the first time
and i was a little drunk too by the way
yeah okay yeah because you're keeping it
[ __ ] real like right there to her
you're questioning her existence
my best friend's hilarious i'm telling
i'm talking to his girlfriend like this
right and i look at him and he just goes
[Laughter]
yeah you know i mean and so i'm walking
to the car and i'm like yo what the [ __ ]
is with her right here's a bro i've been
talking to her about this [ __ ] crazy
behavior that she has like she doesn't
have a lot of friends because she always
does this [ __ ] she always has to like
try to make herself like she's above
people as if she's giving people insight
on [ __ ] he goes i tell her this all the
time but it doesn't mean [ __ ] and he
goes that's the first time she had
somebody stop and didn't check her ass
on the spot and i just denoted
everything that she was doing and she
didn't have anything to say back
and he was like dude he goes honestly
that should feel good yeah you totally
vindicated your bro there too yeah like
he was right the entire time is this
what you've been going through this
whole time yeah like while you were with
her he's like yeah it's tough but you
know he loved her at the time
but i told him i was like hey bro i
[ __ ] hate her
yeah
you let people know yeah you let me know
i was like
i was like hey i'm gonna be respectful
because she's a girl but i don't [ __ ]
like her bro and i was like if that's
how she talks to you i don't [ __ ]
like her yeah you know and
they broke up because of that type of
behavior yeah she needs to go through a
lot of therapy for that [ __ ] but it's
hard to give somebody therapy when they
feel that they're in the counselor
position and they know better yeah that
they've self done self therapy because
they studied the books exactly and that
is the awards those people are legit
like they're borderline personality
disorder
you can't you can't help somebody fix a
problem when they don't recognize it as
a issue or a problem and that's what he
was dealing with this whole [ __ ] time
right but you know for me i don't give a
[ __ ] that's my best friend because this
is what i told her at the end i was like
i don't think you understand this that's
my best friend yeah like i kill for this
guy
for the rest of your life you guys get
married you guys have kids i'm right
there yeah i was like that means that
you and i have to get along yeah i'm
uncle i'ma be around like like this guy
gabo is
damn you're just as close to me as my
blood [ __ ] brother i love this guy to
death he has been there for me for
anything
so
i'm gonna be around you and i have to
get along you cannot speak to me that
way
like ever i don't think you should speak
to anybody that way in that you know
condescending tone where you feel like
you could be dismissive of everything
because of the job position that you
have and as a counselor i have friends
who are a counselor they would never do
that yeah you know you know and i said
my piece and lo and behold they broke up
and i did like when he told me that [ __ ]
i was like
i [ __ ] hated
there's so many guys who are sitting
there waiting and hoping that their man
or their man their boy like their best
friend
will come to their i don't know about
senses but like like really have to face
that real like she had great qualities
too everybody does she has great
qualities too she's really pretty you
know
you know
i guess
yeah
but um you know just talking to her and
just like i i kind of got worried i was
like how are you a counselor how are you
a [ __ ] counselor especially because i
went through counseling a lot for anger
management and none of my counselors
talked to me like that right they would
never ever be dismissive about like
personal stories and just trying to make
you feel bad and like make me judge my
own [ __ ] blood brother are you out of
your [ __ ] mind you know and there was
no listening point it was just immediate
rebuttal no listening didn't even listen
and just just interrupted and rebuttaled
everything i was trying to say what are
you rebutting
like
there's like who's here arguing with you
we're not we're not discussing about the
creation of man yeah i totally just
opened up to you and you're just like
shutting that [ __ ] down yeah i just
heard her [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah i
mean you see me going here like well
actually yeah shooty actually as a man
yeah
she's mad splinting to me and [ __ ] yeah
i'm sick of that [ __ ] man well guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast hope you enjoyed this
conversation talking about getting over
like drug addictions you know dealing
with like divorced friends this is all
real [ __ ] talk and i'm pretty sure a
lot of people are we're not going for
this and we're still a little lost about
it too we just have the questions yeah
we're all trying to figure it out man
you could catch ed at ed park v
p
um
breakfast says breakfast at momo's bible
study breakfast
you're ready to eat bible study
whenever he gets that going you can
follow that and you can catch us genius
brains every sun genius brain every
sunday at 12